[Music]
it's completely understandable that
we're often maddened by what might be
called normal humanity the way in which
emotions so regularly triumph over
careful reasoning the power of group
loyalty even when the group doesn't seem
to deserve much devotion the vast
mechanisms of status seeking that drive
so much excess consumption
widespread selfishness and indifference
to the greater needs of distant others
and we can find ourselves in the privacy
of our heads or in the occasional late
night outburst railing against the fools
and idiots who so unfortunately seem to
occupy so many of the prominent places
of power wealth and influence in our
world
in such moods the 19th century
naturalist charles darwin has much to
say to us
he was born in england in 1809 into a
well-to-do and intellectually
distinguished family he was much
influenced by visiting in his twenties
the galapagos islands where he could see
first-hand species remarkably different
from those that existed elsewhere
in later life he was a quiet rather
withdrawn man he became the world's
leading expert on barnacles
he achieved worldwide fame for his great
work on the origin of species by natural
selection but darwin felt that people
had not quite understood the
implications of his ideas and in 1871
when he was in his 60s he brought out a
title called the descent of man
darwin liked to say that he had thought
of calling his book the ascent of man
but that would suggest some idea of
progress
a concept he did not believe in
rather what darwin wanted to do was to
show that despite the obvious technical
advances of past centuries modern people
are still fundamentally at exactly the
same moral level or even perhaps a
slightly worse level than their remote
ancestors
darwin's big point is that the basic
psychological characteristics of human
beings evolved to aid survival in the
very remote past
at the simplest level we are generally
attracted to sweet things because in the
very extended period of early human
development that meant eating wild
berries which are great for our health
it's only been in very recent times that
this inbuilt desire has turned against
us and given us a craving for
manufactured sugar which by darwin's
time had become a major industrial
commodity
we also evolved to be highly conscious
of our own position within our immediate
group
since so much of our early survival in
the past depended on that so today being
liked feels as if it is a life or death
issue precisely because in the past it
precisely was that it indicated when you
would be served when the spoils of the
hunt were being distributed
practically everything back then
depended on having a mate and
reproducing and so our minds are
massively preoccupied by questions of
reproduction even though today this is
not actually central to our own
individual survival or even happiness
and obviously emotional behavior is much
earlier and much more deeply rooted than
elaborate reasoning which is a very
recent and still terribly fragile
development in human culture
we can put on clothes and drive in cars
but we are still carrying charles darwin
insists our primate heritage
and that though disappointing is not
really our fault it is simply a fact we
need to get used to
charles darwin teaches us in his great
work the descent of man to feel
compassion for the very large primitive
part of who we all are and will always
be
if you liked this film you can download
our app
just follow the link on your screen now
you